This has been on my mind for the past
week.
Yapping.
It's a term I keep hearing and hearing,
and a friend of mine who knows I do
videos about communication said, "Why
haven't you done any yap content yet?"
Or talking about what makes a great yap.
And I was embarrassed.
And I felt old because I didn't know
what that meant. And so I had to
research what is yapping, and I realized
that this is a form of communication,
almost a freestyle
communication form where streamers and
more and more content creators will just
speak at length, almost stream of
consciousness, about a particular topic.
And that might sound boring or that you
wouldn't want to tune into that, but
more and more people are craving this
yap content. It's a rise in popularity.
And I think the reason for that, and I
just created a video about this, is that
I think yapping is great for
communication in general, and one of the
reasons is that the desire for this yap
content signals a desire for
authenticity.
So if we think about
polished communication of the past, so
television,
production, and makeup artists, and
really planned out lines or speeches
that use comfort monitors and are
scripted,
people don't want that.
They want authenticity. They want
thoughts off the top of your head
because it's this inside view of this
raw feeling that they're they're with
you, almost like it's two friends
hanging out and you're just chatting.
And so I actually think that this is an
art form. The ability to yap well is an
art form. And what I wanted to do with
this video, which is turning into a yap,
there's not going to be cuts or edits in
between, it's just going to be as much
off the top of my head as possible, is I
wanted to create a video that applies
certain public speaking ideas or
strategies into how you can make a great
yap. And the first thing is the ability
to have quick impromptu speaking skills.
And this is baked into Toastmasters. I
talk about Toastmasters a lot,
international organization. There's
Toastmasters clubs in most cities,
especially throughout North America, but
globally.
And many Toastmasters clubs have
something called table topics. And the
idea is that you are asked a question
and then you are expected to respond for
1 to 2 minutes. So, the question could
be, if you could be any superhero, which
superhero would you be and why? And then
everyone starts clapping and you come up
to the front of the room or virtually
and you have to answer that for 1 to 2
minutes.
And it's very difficult to do this. It's
one of the hardest parts of
Toastmasters, but it builds that muscle
and that ability to think quickly on
your feet. And that's what yapping's all
about. Yapping is all about the ability
to think quickly, to transition between
thoughts, to keep things somewhat
organized. And so, that is a great
thing. If you have the ability to attend
Toastmasters, super affordable, I
definitely
encourage you to do that. There's so
many other benefits, but again, this
type of art form of
talking, stream of consciousness, this
will help with that. There's also
websites, if you don't want to join
Toastmasters,
there's random question and prompt
generators, conversation starters. And
so, you can use that and you can film
yourself and you can practice speaking
off the top of your head. So, that's the
first thing. The second thing you can do
is actually have some structure to it,
which seems counterintuitive because
yapping is all about the freestyle idea,
but you still have to think about
capturing people's attention. And so,
the idea here, and I would take what I
teach about how to do a proper speech
and I would apply it to yapping. So, you
have the hook, so something that's going
to grab the audience's attention right
away. How I chose to start this video
was there's been something on my mind
lately, yapping.
And [snorts] the reason I did that is
because that's almost like a typical
stereotypical yap is I've been thinking
about this lately and then it gets the
audience's attention. But you want
something, so whether it's jumping right
into a story, giving like a hot take on
something, sharing a surprising
statistic, something that's going to
stop the audience in their tracks cuz
they're scrolling through content, and
get them to want to pay more attention.
Also, this is a bonus tip that has to do
with the hooks, but you want a lot of
visuals throughout. So, I was watching
some other creators' videos talking
about yap content and they were saying
almost every 2 seconds you should have
visuals coming into play to really
capture that audience's attention.
The next thing, so you have your hook,
which is your intro, and then you want
to have two or three points that back up
whatever it is that you're saying. So,
you're talking about
sports or World Cup or a team that's
underrated, why X team is going to win
the World's Cup despite the fact
everyone's written them off.
So, that's the hot take, might be
controversial, especially with something
like World Cup where people have their
beliefs in different teams. So, you give
your hot take and then you give those
reasons that support it. And then toward
the end, you can conclude and wrap
everything up and it's best if you're
able to do that full circle. So, the
first random idea that you had, kind of
bringing it back.
There are many ways you can structure a
yap, but this is one of the ideas of how
you can do so. The next thing you want
to do to make a great yap is to ensure
that you're documenting real-life
experiences that you're having. So, as
you go through your particular day,
think about journaling or having a notes
app on your phone that you're
documenting things that happened. Maybe
they're funny interactions, maybe
they're observations that you had that
day. It's mind-blowing how many things
happen and then if we don't write them
down, we'll totally forget them and
we're on to the next thing. But if you
build the habit of every morning, every
evening, spend 15 minutes in just
writing about that day. It's a really
good practice in general. A lot of the
world's most successful people focus on
journaling, but it's also going to give
you a base of potential content or
things that you can talk about going
forward. And so this is going to help
especially for those of you who want to
be doing more and more of this type of
content.
A bonus tip here is to document your
best stories. So what are the stories
you tell to family members or friends
when you get together for social
gatherings? Often these are funny
stories, maybe they're embarrassing
stories, maybe they're things that
happened that defied all odds like you
had some crazy thing happen at the
casino or, you know, something happened
that
yeah, just there was no business this
thing happening. I can't think of an
example off the top of my head. These
are the types of things to write down in
a notes doc on your phone and I
challenge you right now, anyone watching
this, come up with at least five stories
and start that list. And this is going
to be a living list for you, but this is
the type of thing if you have great
stories that have also already been
social proof that friends or family have
given you feedback or they made people
laugh, you know you can utilize these in
future content, whether that's yap
content, whether that's a formal speech,
but start documenting your daily
activities and start documenting the
stories that happened. The final way to
get really good with yapping is to
actually do it. So, if this is something
you want to work on, freestyle talking
at length,
challenge yourself.
Do a 100-day challenge where you post a
video, and you're not going to do edits,
you're just going to do
off the top of your head talking about a
particular subject. Do that for 100
days, and I promise you, if you actually
do that, you will be so many levels
better at this skill of talking off the
top of your head, getting more
comfortable on camera. I'm going to have
a little rant for a second.
We have been talking about this for so
long, the idea of people wanting to get
more comfortable on camera. How do I
shoot video content? When I
the current job I'm in, when I started
it about 12 years ago, this was the
number one topic, people talking about I
know I need to be doing more video. I
know I need to be doing more video. That
has never changed. That is now more true
than it's ever been, but it's always
been true, and the same people talking
about this 12 years ago are talking
about it now, and you have to. If this
is a skill you want to build, you have
to start doing it. Take action. Don't
romanticize that perfect first video
that you're going to put out that's
going to get millions of views, cuz it
probably won't happen. You could post
every day, and you get similar view
counts, but you never know that one
video that could hit, that could
resonate with people. And so,
do your best to start the habit, start
practicing talking off the top of your
head, get beyond the fear of what other
people are going to think with this
video content. The people who want to
see it will see it. The algorithms are
very good at putting content in front of
people who actually want to consume that
content. So, that is the biggest thing
is to practice yapping.
I hope this video on how to yap,
which is a term that I've just learned
about recently, was beneficial to you.
Let me know, what do you think about
this communication form? I think it is a
great thing in the big scheme of things
because it signals people's desire for
more authenticity. Thank you so much for
watching this video. If you enjoyed it,
check out the one that is popping up
over here and subscribe to my channel.
And by the way, if you want to work on
any of this, if you want to become a
better yapper, a better speaker, reach
out to me. I have a stand store link.
You can also just comment and I will
reach out to you directly, but I would
love to work with you one-on-one.
Thanks for watching this one.